if we can monitor the brain more often
in times when it is not necessarily in
crisis mode yeah we can get a better
understanding of their variables the
effective boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host on
Saucon we are on-site at dr. Loes
stealth residence in the beautiful
Silicon Valley California we are now
gonna be talking about a new paradigm in
brain research we have dr. Phillip Lowe
joining us on the show hello
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you I'm for the conversation going
up to Phoenix nest thank you thank you
gorgeous gorgeous for those who don't
know dr. Phillip Lowe is founder
chairman and CEO of neuro vigil which is
dedicated to the betterment of the human
condition by merging neuroscience
non-invasive wireless beam brain
recording technology in advanced
computational algorithms to rapidly
generate accurate and automated readings
of brain wave data this information is
being used to assist with the data
collection on a myriad of medical
conditions and treatments he's also the
author of the Cambridge declaration on
consciousness the signing of which on
July 7 2012 marked a Copernican moment
in the history of civilization has the
official recognition by scientists of
non-human consciousness and you can find
the links in the bio below to neuro
vigil calm as well as the Cambridge
declaration on consciousness and dr.
Loes Twitter all right so let's start
things off with asking you what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
at what level are we talking about the
scientific world are we talking about
the political world are we talking about
the cultural world what would level you
get to take it okay very good
well I think we are at a very
interesting time certainly you know who
sews prediction has come to fruition in
the sense that we have mature technology
Clee immensely but we have confused that
level of maturity with an idea that we
have also evolved ethically which is not
the case at all and I think we need to
remember that this is sobering it is a
soaking time for us to distinguish
between the two and it is a very
exciting time to be a scientist and an
entrepreneur in order to steer one's
work into the world there is a this is a
time when globalization has gotten a bad
name and fortunately I am and this is a
time when people have exploited that
that that distrust for globalization I
think that is very dangerous because
when we stop collaborating we stop
building upon these nonlinearities which
are so important so I think we are at a
critical time and I think that people
such as yourselves who are actually
educating engaging and inspiring people
are critical because you get to be the
bridge into the this new world that we
are all trying to build which is one
where we can create wonderful
technologies that with an ethical
mindset
it's so frequent now that we have the
guests on the show that we talk to about
this wisdom race that's happening where
our level of ethical and moral evolution
needs to catch up to the democratization
of these exponential technologies and
the way that we interplay geopolitically
so I'm glad that you bring that up as a
central pillar of the direction of our
world we that's massively important to
figure out all right let's jump into who
you were as a kid growing up how did you
even get interested in the fields that
you're in now you know it's interesting
I I think that the moment we understand
who we are we stopped being that person
so we we love to have this idea that you
know we are masters of our destiny
I think nothing is it is it is further
from the truth than that but if I look
back at glimpses of my past I can see
how the dots may have connected in in
some cases so certainly you know I was I
knew from a very young age that that the
brain was fascinating and was very
fragile I knew this from you know an
experience with my father who overdosed
on a particular sleep drug and then
threatened that person with a weapon
that led us to losing everything we had
in one week when I was 10 years old and
then I was always fascinated with
mathematics and physics so I I was
fortunate I graduated very very young I
went to Chicago studied mathematics and
physics and I had some theories about
biology and this was a time when
students in years of Chicago had to take
half of their courses outside of their
expertise and so I took a biology
sequence applied quantitative techniques
and it so happened that there was a
clerical mistake which because of which
my name was not removed from a mailing
list and then Harvard Medical School
wanted to take a student from you
go they chose me even though it was math
geek and then I worked in laboratory for
a few weeks end up loving it wrote a
letter to Francis Crick who was in
neuroscience and you know a molecular
biologist asking him for guidance he
invited me to come to Salk Institute for
my PhD I worked first for a year in
Chicago on sleeping birds joined the
Salk Institute invented an algorithm to
analyze brain patterns during sleep and
then you know started my my company and
when the entrepreneurial route so it was
a a a path that I certainly did not plan
yeah and the influence that you had when
you were so young of what happened to
your father and how something as complex
as taking a what had been made as a
sleeping pill gonna have such an adverse
effect on our behavior right and then to
set yourself on to see yourself now on
this where you're at now is like wow
what a profound moment in my trajectory
that that had silly ironic yeah yeah
yeah and also you you also took a big
you know you you really have to we'll
talk about this towards the end but
these risks that you took with going out
and to Harvard for the period of time to
start analyzing the sleep patterns and
birds what and then to also write the
letter to Francis Crick to get out to
sockets to I mean these are massive took
it risk he took a risk with also boil a
you know yeah that's it for your PhD and
stuff yeah yeah yeah this is this is
another reoccurring theme in him and so
even now I mean getting all the way to
like what you actually did so there's so
so what we saw in the old days we saw
the you know ten even ten years ago just
such like a bulky you call it octopus
some legs array of Alden erode
knowledge and to be able to find out
that you can take something like a
single electrode and be able to write an
algorithm that's able to make sense of
data of brain wave data was a profound
realization at that time true and and it
was that surely was a gamble and it
started in the following way
there was a a student at the University
of Chicago who had discovered that zebra
finches songbirds appear to rehearse a
song when it was sleeping and basically
there's a particular brain structure
that is very active while the bird is
singing and lo and behold when the bird
was sleeping you could see that pattern
you know I really even though the bird
was sleeping yeah
and so that caused a huge competition
between Caltech MIT and Chicago to
figure out in what state of sleep this
was going on and I thought this was a
good good project to be involved in
after a year Caltech and MIT published
their findings and did not show any REM
sleep in these birds and I knew that
this was wrong because birds are very
photosensitive so I let them sleep a
little bit longer in the hope of
catching REM sleep and I monitored them
with security cameras infrared and sure
enough later in the night I could see
that the eyes were moving and it didn't
appear that they were waking up the big
question was why is it that nobody could
capture the change in our physiology
from story of sleep to another state
like REM sleep and I went to to sulk and
then I realized the middle of my first
year what it was the brain anatomy is
very different and people were using
coordinates there was similar to the
mammalian coordinates there was one
issue and another issue that one of the
teams had is they created implants they
were quite uncomfortable and we know
that stress
Changez sleep architecture quite a bit
yeah so I took it I explained this to my
mentors at Salk and I said you know I
think we have to put the electrodes very
close one from the other and make a
superlight implant and sure enough you
know I went back to Chicago and this
should show that these birds had REM
sleep they had an intermediate sleep
state that they had brain patterns that
were thought to belong only to mammals
even though they didn't have a mammalian
brain and that led to two different
things
you know I had wonderful help with
Chicago I trained another student who
was able to replicate these findings but
I also and he will did some beautiful
work on um had miss farik see this is
when half of the brain is awake and the
other half is asleep but it led to two
things fundamentally one was the
algorithm to the nun lies these patterns
automatically and I was told that it was
impossible to do this that we needed at
least you know I movements at muscle
tone that maybe sleep states were
thought to be a certain number you know
just the basic basic invention there was
a fellow in Japan who thought it may be
seven or nine sleep states and so coming
up with a mathematical formalism to do
this was you know a a big bet and people
did not want me to do this in fact I was
forbidden to actually work on this and I
I did because I thought this was a great
opportunity to do something new and I
wanted bet that's what my thesis
officially is one page all kinds of
patents and so on in the appendix but I
sure that mathematically could separate
the steep stages and on the other hand
there were people like Francis Crick who
were looking at the data and they would
say what does it birds ability to have
REM sleep to us about consciousness and
so years later I was able to rally newer
scientists from all over the world I'd
written this document which became known
as the Commission declaration on
consciousness and what we pretty much
did is we took a we pretty much did a
Turing test for consciousness in other
words we looked at all these different
brains and and looked at all the
similarities between them
and we were looking for this
continuity's and what we realized was
that the most different parts of our
brains did not appear to be necessary
for certain behaviors for which
consciousness was necessary and because
of that the idea the Cartesian notion
that consciousness was limited to humans
fell and that was that what you call
this Copernican moment which you know is
now leading us in a new direction and in
the world will probably treat other
sentient beings a bit better yes and
this is also interesting as so many
people in our past have been so
spiritually connected to source into
nature and the deeper understanding that
other creatures also have feelings that
we similarly do and that it took funny
to think that it took this long for
scientists a need to say that octopuses
and birds and even their dogs and our
cats that are in so many of our homes
what exhibit consciousness yeah that's
what I mean if you look at it from from
one particular standpoint
you know when I started my PhD I asked
three eminent neuroscientists the same
question if animals are not conscious
why do we anesthetize them you know how
could they feel any pain if they're not
conscious and the first one said oh this
is a political problem don't worry about
it we have people who lobby for us I was
quite surprised to to hear him say this
the second one said well we understand
sighs him for two reasons this is a
practical one we don't want him to move
during a surgery but we also want to
make sure that in case they are
conscious we wouldn't want to cause pain
so we do this for our own sake and in
this third scientist said well clearly
they are conscious and and we are using
them for our own purposes and we want to
minimize their pain and I was surprised
by his admitting this and I said you
know I hope I did not cause you to to be
visited by demons right now and he said
no I I'm visited by them every day I was
quite surprised he said we'll be
remembered as butchers later on and this
is a person who worked with with
primates so if we look at it through the
lens of history you know I mean the
numbers are staggering what is it a
hundred million well yes we're so sure
about a hundred hundred million
vertebrates are sacrificed by industry
academia and governments every year
according to some numbers I've seen 40
billion is spent every year the
likelihood that we will actually test a
drug is about 6% and about 98% of those
well fails this is whether you're an
animal lover or not this is very
wasteful yeah
efficacy needs to get better in this
process well we just need to move that
we need to change the paradigm and we
need to instead of waiting for people to
be completely sick we need to actually
get data from them when they appear to
be healthy still when they're
asymptomatic
and when our chances of correcting
whatever is going on reduce chances are
higher that I think needs to happen and
changing the whole world into a
laboratory and using real population
data is key but if you look at you know
all of this with lens of history well
remember it starts with a white Greek
male the white Greek male stands alone
and everything around him is deemed to
be barbarian over the century is that
radius extends a little bit so now you
know Persians are seen to to not be
barbarian Latin America and it is
conquered in America general there is a
a priest from the Inquisition who says
his name was bottom de las casas he says
why are we giving a Christian name to
these natives either they're animals and
they do not deserve a Christian name or
they are human beings and the Quran
could have a soul and we should not be
enslaving them you know so these ethics
have evolved Wow but yeah but we're
committing the same hubris not with the
animals so you are yeah so you know
eventually their engines have have more
rights women are recognized by the by
the Pope as having assault that took if
you if you hundreds of years as well and
if you look at you know what happened
during the Holocaust it's always this
idea that a group is distinct from
others
and when when people start believing
this this is when they determine eyes
others yeah and II do horrible things to
them and I'm quite scandalized when you
know a country such as America which
which which did try to live up to the
ideals of democracy even though this is
a country that was founded on genocide
and slavery abandons these ideas and
treats our neighbors to the south you
know worse than Nazi war criminals we
did you know half shampoo soap and
toothpaste so I think you know the the
decart hadn't introduced this difference
between human animals non-human animals
and the kimbridge occupation reversed
that and so we're living at a very
exciting time now because we are
recalibrating our understanding of who
we are in the universe yeah and it does
at times feel like in all earlier times
of human evolution that there were
likely deeper connections to the Spirit
in the other as one that was just like
my own and so then it seems like way
more of there was a lot of tribalism but
whatever religion did to need to
dehumanize like you were describing in
some instances as well complex let's
touch on the democratization of neuro
technology and and also what it means
when we now have all of this more simple
smaller able to analyze and
map what's going on in our brain on a
moment-to-moment basis you had this very
interesting moment in your TEDMED talk
when you asked the audience how many of
you have neuropathology and no one
raised their hand and then you ask them
how when was the last time you got a
brain scan and again people were like I
haven't gotten a brain scan and so you
need a moment-to-moment biometric
analysis of your brain of your body in
order to really be able to predict the
development of pathologies and that's a
big part of the future of neural vigil
and just medicine in general it's it's
part of the president you know so we've
been doing this we've we have we have
implemented vision we've worked with
some of the world's biggest former
companies and we've actually created
maps of brain activity in individuals
who were undergoing all kinds of
treatment on the research a basis but we
have found some interesting things and
so now when it comes to democratization
the idea is to make the probe smaller
and smaller made them available to
people all over the world at a very low
cost so that we can actually track
individuals and enable them to record
their brain data as easily as they may
be able to record their heart data some
people will say well you know I I only
am interested in an EEG if it has you
know 12 leads or 16 leads I think that
if you if you do that then it doesn't
become portable so if you use some
serious AI and you have enough probes
out there and you can you can screen
people longitudinally then you can
actually whatever percentage of
bandwidth you feel that you may be
losing by going with fewer channels you
more than recoup that accuracy by
contrasting the data within people and
across people more people with a single
electrode can provide you with very
valuable insights versus one person turn
into a pin cushion yeah absolutely
because because again you know this is
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle for
biology if you turn people into a pin
cushion you are going to actually
change their physiology as well you're
going to affect them in any way so we
want you know we're creating probes that
are very very gentle very very elegant
so that we can actually put them a lot
of people and may we take a look at the
eye brain well here's a little one you
know so it's a library so now we've got
we're in a stage of the company where we
have about you know 60 international
patents and we've done work in many
different directions we've helped
Stephen Hawking we created a system so
that if he ever became completely
paralyzed
by the end of his life we would be able
to actually bring him back and enable
them to communicate so we actually
patented this their biomarkers of intent
and now we have a number of you know
trillion dollar companies didn't want
licenses to this technology we've got
companies that are interested in the
small device that we have we have
companies are interested in it Parkinson
sensor so now we're using this IP in
order to create a number of new
opportunities and to attract people who
are excited in by those verticals this
is a tiny little eyebrow for example you
know so this is this is all there is
you've got everything in there you've
got you've got the the battery you have
to transmission to the phone and you
know we're still going to do a lot of
testing on these types of devices NASA
is interested in them but but that's a
really small footprint you know I think
if he was Newsweek that's called it a
Fitbit for the brain I think it's much
better for the brain but that's the idea
something that's very very simple very
gentle that you can put a lot of people
and then I can take something as simple
as the eye brain and place it on what
forehead is that the best place for you
know unless you have a hairy forehead
which you don't have such a good good
place and then I'm usually wearing that
with some sort of a comfortable strap to
hold it in you know the the the
electrode is adhesive its adhesive so so
I can use these adhesive straps to keep
it on and then so then through then
there's a process of the the the bio
signal
is then being processed by your
technology what the algorithms the
devices are very easy to build these
algorithms are must be extremely complex
to be able to understand a bio smell of
intent something like that is like what
Wow
well you know it's I've been doing this
for a while so so so it doesn't appear
complex to me you know but you know
making violins may not appear may not
have appeared complexes Freddie virus
either you know after a while you get
pretty good at pattern recognition but a
fundamental thing that people had to
understand was that you know EE G's are
1 over F so that means that the higher
frequencies by going to have less power
and power goes with the square of the
amplitude so there's a 1 over R square
relationship between frequency and
amplitude think about it this like like
waves in the ocean while you can have
these very very big waves but they're
slow or you could have these little
ripples here you know
high frequency but you know less power
and so the first thing to realize was
that it could be statistically
significant changes in these via high
frequencies that were not observable
initially if one only focused on world
power so that was the first step and
then there are all kinds of machine
learning algorithms that you can use I
like favour unsupervised ones because
you know if you do a supervised neural
net then you can't actually discover
more than what you already know and I
think that's that's risky so I love to
use unsupervised nets on these types of
data but interestingly you know the the
algorithms that we created worked
initially a nucleated initially for
sleep but in a we created algorithms
that were geared towards wakefulness and
intent and and that's quite quite
interesting right when we have a person
who actually communicated and was able
to spell his name or
you know just simply City what
communicate you know without moving
mm-hmm so so then we're the bio the a
bio signal that's common then is either
like a lower frequency or a higher
frequency or something in the middle the
whole thing is to get the pattern if I
get a pattern to get it had a pattern of
the frequency over time it pattern
changes in relative shift in frequencies
over time relative shifts and
frequencies over time okay and then then
sleep stages can be determined from this
before potentially things like the onset
of neuro pathologies can potentially do
so what you can do is once you have
certain signatures all right that
correspond to particular brain areas for
example you can then track these brain
areas over time and see if that
signature is affected over time either
naturally or by some compound okay we
can potentially show the the efficacy of
in clinical trials may I just filed a
patent actually do you know yeah
absolutely you know showing particular
signatures that were being affected by
certain compounds yeah okay yeah so did
all the numbers that you were mentioning
earlier with our need to increase
efficacy in clinical trials can be
augmented through patents like what you
just filed well we need to well the
pharma industry I mean I had a very
famous oncologist who
watch me in Beverly Hills a few weeks
ago why the fall - we hadn't put a hit
on me which I thought was a pretty good
question coming on the heels of a
Chilean reporter who asked me why they
the meat industry hadn't put a hit on me
so even really strange questions these
days but not everybody likes to know
that you can actually check whether a
particular compound has a signature on
the brain
you know because especially compound
makers if they've invested a lot of
resources like you believe that their
signatures are just clean we find all
kinds of interesting things
Wow it'll be great identify those that
are have self-dealing proclivities and
and that's a huge problem this huge it's
a huge problem and it's like we were
talking about earlier it's just it's
still going on right now so so so for
instance the science and math are
complex and so that also it's about it's
about greed by giving example when my
father had this adverse reaction to his
sleep drug
turns out that the company that created
that drug had data showing that this
drug had some major side effects and
they just tried to sweep everything
under the rug
in fact many years later when I created
neuro vigil I'm a co-founder pierson-el
ski with a leader in artificial
intelligence and one of my PC advisors
but around that time I met with a French
billionaire who I was interviewing as a
potential investor in the company and he
brought with him a gentleman who
actually admitted in the middle of the
negotiation that he had been hired by
that pharma company in order to create a
decent formation campaign afterwards and
this is still going on and so why are
the reasons I'm excited about having
technology that is a wearable that
people can have immediately and directly
is that even if this technology may not
diagnose them if we can notice that it's
a change and and get a physician to look
at their data and diagnose them there's
a level of there's not a level of
vigilance there that I think is very
important too often many physicians act
like drug pushers you know if they don't
feel some quota they're not invited to
the retreat in Hawaii
there are eminent physicians in the u.s.
who will go on
you know nightly news shows and pitch
all kinds of products that they actually
have you know financial incentives in
pitching and they don't expose those and
I've actually I've been known for going
after a number of them I think if we can
give a wearable to people but avoid the
self diagnosis because I think there's a
trap there too then we shift the power
back to the people and that's where we
need to be you
and now let's explain how that will
happen so then as you identify the
patterns in bio signals you're also
showing the person that's wearing this
data on their phone so then yeah so then
is this I was the first person to have a
beam brain wave did on the phone as far
as I know being buried you know I was 10
years ago that was well I showed it at
TEDMED and you know that patent was
issued a number of jurisdictions already
yeah that I mean the phone is just a
vehicle to get yeah to get these
insights that it can be preventive
medicine that can there can be a
beautiful way of being able to live
healthier now now then
well yeah yeah more data more and more
insights so then so then when when would
someone be able to to take something
like the the I brain and be able to wear
it around with them sure so so so you
know I've been on market now for 10
years so but everything has been done
through Pharma so what we're doing now
is we're creating a number of new of new
subsidiaries new affiliates new
companies one of them is a wearable
company so assuming that we find you
know I mean if we find the right
partners you know then and the right
people to staff that company then you
know we will be able to to bring the
technology to those markets but I'm more
interested in getting the technology in
the hands of people who need them the
most
so who are the most vulnerable people
the elderly populations the other one I
remember the organization for yeah so
Asha is the American senior housing
association yeah so you did 20,000
elderly brains me monitor no we did a
deal with a member of Asha they do sign
you know it's for large amount they
haven't delivered on that part yet I'm
not going to call them out but certainly
when they go shooting with other
partners as well national members yeah
but I think that that's certainly any
you have a lot of people who are over
medicated there I think at least getting
some data and providing that to
physicians would be very very valuable
yes
and that's why I'd like to start and
then also another really interesting one
that just went through last year was to
deal with Wyoming as well it does make a
lot of sense with being the 10th largest
state as we're having is it the least
population 80,000 people
yeah yeah and so then being so sparsely
populated and then being able to do
things like have this this extra data
about the elderly especially can help
with them living longer saving more
lives you've got a huge issue in the
winter is that because they wrote the
snowed on them and they have a number of
people who are over reporting false
emergencies right so just reporting
false emergencies that's obviously an
over report and you have some people who
are undergoing real emergencies we're
not getting the attention of the nation
so Wyoming is extremely interested in
having access to any type of
physiological home-based monitor so not
just the ones that you know near a vigil
is building or planning on building but
also a number of our partners and so
we're creating this thing called you
know an accelerator right now and the
first batch of companies will be about
ten five will be nervous all
subsidiaries the other five are you know
other partners I can describe them a
little bit if you're interested yes
please yeah so I'm happy to do that but
Wyoming wants to be the first state that
sort of California to have access to
these technologies another country that
is interested in having access to this
technology besides the United States is
Argentina so Argentina provides free
health care not only to the Argentine's
but to the neighbors as well and with
the 17% official unemployment rate and
with about 37 percent of people of
working age who cannot get a full-time
job that is not a sustainable model and
so they want to also put a big emphasis
on preventive health I just gave a
speech to
don't session of Congress over there I
met with the Speaker of the House in
Argentina I met with an adviser to
president Macri and with the cabinet
member you know it looks like I'll go
back to meet with president Macri as
well so they get it and they want to
help also on the clinical trial side
they have to change their export laws in
order to to export anything that may be
manufactured there the Chileans are also
very interested they have wonderful
institutions great export laws and we're
already looking at space on a campus in
in Santiago Chile I was just there and
we're also you know we also have an
offer on space in Wyoming so we want to
go and work with people who need these
things the most and I think that's that
that's a more powerful proof of concept
and you know if you look at what what
we're interested in in terms of near a
vigil were interested in Parkinson's
sensing so so it turns out that there
are biomarkers that that give to pop up
about 15 years before the onset of
Parkinson's you know that's very very
important 15 years ago for the whole
nonsense that's a that's a that's a
really good a long window absolutely so
so you know if it didn't have disease so
you know people may say well why would
you want to know you know why would you
want to be freaked out this way I'll
tell you why you want to know because
there are now a number of environmental
factors that have been isolated which
may contribute to Parkinson's and so
certainly knowing that you may be at
risk and giving you the option to engage
in certain behaviors that might decrease
the likelihood of developing football in
Parkinson's I think that's valuable so
so we know for example that you know if
you look at Parkinson's genes the
sensitivity is about 16% you know that's
not huge RBD REM behavior disorder which
is a disease that is characterized by
maintaining muscle tone during REM sleep
well it turns out that according to some
experts in Canada if you have our
beading the likelihood that you all have
Parkinsons within another 15 years if
you live in another 15 years is nearly
hundred percent so that's nearly 100
percent specificity and the about a
third of part of of parkinsonian have
IBD so the sensitivity is more than
twice the most sensitive part in some
streams so you certainly you would want
to know if you have a video or not
because I was able to show
mathematically that you can distinguish
between REM and wakefulness on a single
channel we can just add in another
channel and and and see if the muscle
tone is on or off yeah well so we're
interested in that we're interested in
the wearable space we are interested in
mind control interfaces that work with
it with and for Stephen Hawking we're
interested in bo-best ohm finding out if
you actually have a change in physiology
that could be a negative of a brain
tumor I met with a very prominent
inventor Southern California just
recently who wants to team up on that
and we're also interested in in pulling
all of that sensor data and doing real
very rigorous AI on that so that's on
the NV side if you look at the partner
side there's a TMS company on the East
Coast they have about five million in
revenue they've been using the
technology for bipolar disorder they
want to stimulate the substantia [ __ ]
which is affected by Parkinson's we'll
see if they if they do a good job with
that but they are they applying there is
a Stanford Lisbon spin-off working on
what they call a 4d bioreactor the idea
is to replicate the blood-brain barrier
in vitro there was a drug called turn
fear about many years ago it received
about a billion dollars of investment
and it flunked in Phase three because
it's not even caused by brain barrier so
basically the you know the Phase two
data was underpowered it was it was
fluff and so you know if we had a way to
just test that in vitro that could be a
very good thing there is a company that
wants to create injectable brain parts
you know it sounds like sci-fi but you
know if you're not if you're working on
something
Sify then you're not innovating right
now you know so they actually have some
really interesting technology and the
the for the bioreactor company has
technology that is that it is applicable
to what they're building as well
so they're number of people you know who
applying there's an MIT wearable
spin-off as well there's not a wearable
in a Parkinson's space so we're we're
creating you know the best-in-class
we're not creating infomercials for one
university or another we're creating a
business environment that is so so so so
much in favor of the entrepreneur I know
this having been you know on this side
and staying on this as an entrepreneur
we're not taking any equity you know
it's not it's not a mandate of ours
we're just taking royalties you know and
after them after the services are we
paid that the world he goes down to 1%
so the idea is to give the best terms
possible you know you have VCC they're
all so they're all different but then
you look at the term she they all doing
the same thing they're taking a 2%
management feet and they're taking a 20%
cut that's if they make money and if you
don't make money they're not punished
you know so it's a very interesting
model we don't take any management fee
10% should go to the Department of
nature maintenance of all venture
capital it's an interesting thought but
but but what we're doing is we are not
charging the LPS anything right and this
world
there's no the LPS no there's no
management fee there's no 20% cut I can
invest in the companies or through sue
and V and the portfolio companies just
pay royalty and and and you know they do
royalty I dropped it to 1% which is
pretty pretty damn good and they are
provided with legal services where
accounting services which space anything
they need in order to get to you know
through them through the value of death
as we call it right get to market and
we've got people in Wyoming other places
who are already showing that they want
to to explore these technologies so I
think it's going to be have been ups for
the brain I think it's going to be very
exciting not a single animal will be
killed or used
you know in in the process this is all
biomarker based human biomarker based
and I think it's going to be vey
exciting yeah this is truly a new
paradigm in brain research from not
using animals also with having a new way
of structuring the neuro technology
acceleration of these projects and be
able to get the interest of people from
around the world and the minds that
creates potential from around the world
and helping also unlock the potential of
underprivileged people and help them so
I just created the foundation you know
well I brought back to life in
foundation is it foot initially created
years ago but it was not used now it's
being brought back to life and it has it
is three full side the first one is to
do exactly what you say which is to to
provide job training for people who are
underprivileged so they can actually
integrate the booming new technology
industry you know this is something that
the company has done for many years but
we like we like for all the new
universal companies to to offer
internships as well and a foundation can
certainly provide for that the the other
element is when these new technologies
are offered in very small batches the
price is quite consequent you know
people complain about healthcare in the
states and a very good reason to but we
are also the first ones having access to
some fantastic technology and that is
part of the problem it's multifaceted
it's part of God so we want to make sure
that the foundation can reduce the cost
significantly you know for individuals
working out of for these technologies
when these technologies I have the
approved I think that's going to be very
important and you know I I created the
French scribner oil conference which was
held in Cambridge UK July 7th 2012 and
certainly if if there were to be other
conferences the
the foundation could host those and also
provide busing and you know reduce cost
or waive fees for individuals who would
otherwise not have access to that to
that content yeah the vision extends
into a lot of important facets of of our
world and definitely love that about
whether you see things in the way that
you're pursuing this new paradigm
there's so many aspects of this that we
can still unpack in detail which we can
I think do on on further conversations I
want to at least get your thoughts on on
this on the way out with all of the
emerging exponential technologies with
the amount of the democratization of
these technologies and with our ability
to create these powerful algorithms that
can make sense of the data that we're
getting mm-hmm
and as something as simple as a single
electrode can be suit different yeah
single channel can be worn discreetly
with us throughout the day and have that
fourth dimension of time with us then
where does the future of neuro
technology
hmm am I gonna be getting this on my you
know moment-to-moment basis my the state
of my body all my biometrics I get that
that notification that 15 years oh my
gosh it's starting to well for that
caribou so that you wouldn't have to
actually wear it you know every day but
it's basically it's it it's interesting
right I mean the more if you make the
technology very compact you might lose
some bandwidth for example but you might
also be able to put in way more people
and get some wit statistics so you know
the the the work you know I went from
birds to humans so sleeping birds
sleeping humans and then we're talking
to waking humans you know the the the
idea is for the whole world to become a
major you know laboratory yeah you know
and and and the more we can actually get
data from people as they're behaving and
going about you know their lives the
less the less corrupted that data will
be so so you know we've been treating
the brain as this black box you know we
find information about it you know about
it after this been a major crash and
that's going to be changing we're going
to be aware of things that are happening
in our brain before we present symptoms
and that means that a number of
treatment options that have so far been
failures you know my proof to actually
be you know very very protective of the
brain if implemented at the right time
it means that we will get a better
understanding of the impact that diet
has for example there's a lot of data
for example on Parkinson's and dairy you
know and it's interesting you know
there's a lot of data on red meat and
and cancer you know now I'm a vegan you
might say you know you we have to
control for your veganism and I'll say
we have to control for your not veganism
because I want to look at the set at the
located data there is something that
that that seems to be significant and we
have to see if there's a mechanism
behind those things so I think that
if we if we understand if we can monitor
the brain more often in times when it is
not necessarily in crisis mode you know
we can get a better understanding of the
variables that affect it totally it's a
great way to put it
we so frequently just go in to health
for healthcare when we're in crisis mode
and this is probably most evidently felt
when we get sick when you finally
realize how grateful we are for being
held we take better care is a bit icky
about cars - none of our brains that's
ridiculous ridiculous yeah we we need to
have a more frequent check-in with the
with the complex biology that's
happening with inside of us and so I'm
really looking forward to those days and
they're actually you know with things
like the social genome and what's going
on with that there's just a 10 episode
talking about that as well there's some
very interesting future that even we
couldn't predict a couple decades ago
that we would have these you know
instant drone deliveries instant cars to
pick us up instant video communications
across the planet all these types of
things and now we can't predict that
we're gonna be doing the things with our
matching to people based on our genetics
or to do other nuts things like editing
out diseases or augmenting our ability
so we're really it's beautiful to be
there at these moments of being able to
figure out how biotech and neuro tech
are just going to be
causing a serious yeah shift and and you
know we're also going to piss off a lot
of people and that's good you know
because because the the number of
failures you know could have been
addressed a long time ago and so we know
we're fighting people who are very
entrenched you know just like with a
chemical declaration you know we had
people who were to argue against their
own self-interests because they were
working with animals right so so we have
to look at the data and we have to do
what's right and so the the innovators
you know will get a lot of the fire but
that's fine that's what it was where we
here for yeah yeah there's been so many
instances of the fighting of the
movement of the new paradigm as
especially with people that have the old
paradigm in their pockets you may want
to keep it and that's a major part of
what we talked about on the show is
updating the code of our world
shattering through though old the old
paradigm brain the new fourth and be
inspired to do so through the guests
that we have that talk about what
they're working on let's actually wrap
on exactly that you've had a very
complex entrepreneurial journey that you
were referencing you can look back at
and yeah connect some of the dots along
the way but you persevered you know
through the tests of faith and this is
so important for so many of the young
people that wash for so many of the
guests that we have on give us some of
your thoughts around the importance of
embodying that entrepreneurial spirit
and going through those tests of faith
I think you've got to decide why are you
doing what you're doing you know now if
something is a passion you may never
understand it on a very fine level
because by definition you know we are
passive visa vie something that exerts a
huge force on us but I would say don't
be an entrepreneur just call yourself an
entrepreneur the entrepreneurs I know
don't call themselves entrepreneurs they
tell you about what they're building you
know and and when you and when that
happens then you've got a mission and
you have a purpose and and it becomes
much harder to stop because you know
that there's a whole vision that relies
on you you know if you're doing it for
your ego to play about the things you
can do for you go you know so I think
you know find something that's way
bigger than yourself and sure I mean
when when I wrote the Declaration I knew
that there was a very good chance that
my career was over
you know but I thought that that that's
just one life when I did the algorithm
you know and I was told not to do it
because people for 50 years tried to do
this that was exactly why I needed I
needed to do it because I thought this
is a chance to have impact do something
positive and when people abandon you
that's a very good thing they are doing
you a favor whether that is an investor
who you know doesn't this thing we're
doing anymore or a person in your life
if y'all say or a friend that's a good
thing they're doing you a favor
they are lessening your load if your
passion does not excite them this should
be nowhere in your cur system you know
so I would say don't take no for an
answer
I understand why you're in this do not
give up you know now I don't understand
if there are different ways of doing
certain things absolutely
learn for sure but you know if your
vision is one that
would be your biggest gift to the world
then you're stealing from the world and
you're stealing from yourself by not
going forward with it I love that yeah I
love how you use the word intent as well
we build things that transcend us that
transcend our ego that are for the
betterment of our world and not for fame
greed corruption those types of
tendencies those old codes are dying in
the new codes of building a better world
that transcends us is the future and
also another one is looking looking at
the the Cambridge declaration on
consciousness it's a in so many ways
it's exactly the styles of declarations
that we need moving forward so we need
more especially young people to be
thinking what are these declarations
that you can write today yeah because 50
years from now people will look at this
time and say I can't believe you were
slaughtering these billions of animals
for food so what are the declarations
that we can write today so well you know
that I think that's a great question as
far as I was concerned it needed to
happen even though you know up until the
night before we did not know that it was
going to happen I mean there was some
very prominent scientists who said we
don't sign declarations and I said
actually if you're not signing you are
actually implicitly you know validating
the cards declaration and there's no
data on that whatsoever that that we
should be the only conscious species so
and then then also what scientists don't
issue the versions that's actually not
true if you look there was a conference
in Hawaii in the 80s they declared umami
it takes the fifth taste and this was
after decades of research and so it okay
we have decades of research on these
non-human brains you know and it's
pretty clear that what distinguishes us
from them there's an appeal to be
necessary for features for which the
consciousness is necessary therefore you
know we cannot assume that we are the
only conscious beings anymore
by the way in terms of AI that's quite
interesting because if it means that an
octopus with 500 million neurons you
know can actually be in three hearts is
that right the very very very very very
very interesting but but but but you
know if you're knocked opposed with far
fewer neurons then we have can produce
something that that seems to to do
display elements of consciousness then
you know it means that the it means two
things it means that the conditional
probability of finding conscious life
given the probability of finding life in
the universe far higher than we thought
number one does not need to be
anthropomorphize like humans that's good
I found in so many places yes yes and
number two even on some of our means
yeah and and number two the the the
likelihood of creating artificial
consciousness may not be as low as
people may have thought it was so you
know it mean it gets us to thinking a
little bit differently Wow Philip I've
had a great time talking to quite
amazing questions thank you so much you
so much for coming thank you to your
team yes you shout out to Ron Faso
producer and director thank you very
much Ronnie thank you Phillip they're
coming on greatly thank you for me you
say that huge thing love yeah I think
you forward to doing follow-ups on short
where yeah neuro vigil is heading yeah
and where the industry is going this is
very exciting stuff and how we are
living healthier lives we'd love for
everyone to check out the links in the
bio below again to neuro vigil calm as
well as the Cambridge declaration on
consciousness go and check that out and
share that with more people so we can
have more of these stop provoking
discussions with our friends or families
or co-workers people online on social
media get talking about these things get
talking more also about things like the
future of neuro technology and
biotechnology and where we're heading
with that get inspired to write your own
also declarations that we so desperately
need and be sure to also
understand that your talents in your
genius should not be subservient to your
ethics so start with you ethics and then
you know draw upon your talents and your
imagination to meet them to meet the
ethical challenges that you want to be
solve them and everyone check out the
links in the bio to simulation we really
need you to start helping the
entrepreneurs the artists the spiritual
leaders to help them succeed support
them in their processes go and do it
yourself support them and grow and
create yourselves our links are below to
our patreon crypto-currency paypal our
design cool merch and get paid links
down there go and do all those things
guys help us continue to be cool things
like coming on-site for interviews and
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world thank you very
much for tuning in everyone we will see
[Music]